all right dr. Michael Eman is a
distinguished professor of atmospheric
science and director of the Earth System
science Center at Penn State University
dr. Mann welcome to the show thanks Dave
it's great to be with you so I'm very
happy to be talking to you today because
I talk politics all the time it is
endless politics left-right craziness
Republican Democrat now I'm pretty sure
they're going to end the world but you
focus on something else that might beat
it it might beat politics standing the
world climate science well yeah I mean
some some people called it the science
of doom because we are you know studying
you know this problem climate change
human-caused climate change that has
grave implications for all of you know
civilization now you know the the earth
won't end because of climate change the
real question is will we preserve an
earth that we can thrive on especially
with a growing population nearing 70 no
more than 7 billion we're on our way to
9 10 11 billion people and yet if we
allow climate change to proceed if we
allow the warming of the globe to
continue and all the impacts that that
has we'll see you know a lot more
competition for diminishing food and
water and land and that's deeply
problematic national security experts
who studied the implications of the
projected changes in climate will tell
you that for those reasons this is
really one of the greatest threats that
we face even from a security standpoint
yeah decades ahead and you know some of
this it sounds like a joke when we hear
our leaders say well something like
Syria is partly related to climate
change and I've even joked about it
because it sounds so silly but when you
have diminishing resources people do all
kinds of crazy things but let's just
start we're going to do climate science
101 I really want to unpack some basic
stuff so that people so that next time
someone on Twitter is yelling at me
about it's a hoax I can say here's the
video here's the stuff so let's just
start simply man-made
I'm it change is it real and how do you
know that it is real yeah so it
literally is the consensus of the
world's scientific community that
climate change is real and it's human
cost and you know the US National
Academy of Sciences has weighed in with
that conclusion this is the most
authoritative scientific body in the
nation and it was actually initiated by
a Republican President Abraham Lincoln
hard to believe now right so you know
too sometimes some of the critics or are
from the Republican side of the aisle
when you you know when it comes to
climate change you find that a lot of
the skepticism and the contrarian ism
does come from one side of our political
spectrum and I like to remind those
folks that you know this you know the
Republican Party actually embraced
science for a long time and in fact even
presidents you know Nixon Bush George
Herbert Walker Bush Ronald Reagan
actually acted on global environmental
problems and saw a role for you know
market-based solutions to these problems
so it shouldn't be a partisan political
issue it's unfortunate that it has
increasingly become one but science you
asked about the basics how do we know
that this is happening why is it that
there is such a robust scientific
consensus that every scientific society
in the u.s. in Europe around the world
that's weighed in has said has come to
the conclusion that climate change is
real it is human caused when you say
when you say robust real quick it's
something like 97% of the scientists in
this field correct so this isn't we're
not talking seventy thirty I mean we're
talking really margin of error kind of
stuff right that's right and in fact in
one recent survey they argued is closer
to ninety nine that the study that found
ninety seven percent was sort of bending
over backwards to you know to make
concessions to the critics okay and a
more accurate number might be closer to
ninety nine percent so yeah if you go to
a scientific meeting if you read a
peer-reviewed scientific journal you're
not finding scientists contesting
the globe is warming or even that it's
human-caused the real debate when it
comes to the science is about you know
just how much warming will we see and
precisely what will the impacts of that
warming be but the scientific community
is no longer doubting that climate
change is real and human caused it and
the reason for that is this is really
basic physics and chemistry that goes
back nearly two centuries there's a
scientist Joseph Fourier now he gave us
the Fourier series in mathematics and he
gave us the law of heat conduction the
way you describe how heat moves through
objects was Fourier this guy lived in
the early 1800s he understood that there
was an atmospheric greenhouse effect
okay so over literally over a period of
two hundred years we've we've been
refining our understanding of this
problem but the basics that certain
gases in our atmosphere warm the
atmosphere warm the surface of the globe
that's fundamental science that's been
known for nearly two centuries we
wouldn't be able to explain why Venus is
as warm as it is or why Mars is as cold
as it is if it weren't for our
understanding of the greenhouse effect
the u.s. air force wouldn't be able to
design heat-seeking missiles because to
design a heat-seeking missile you need
to program in information about the heat
absorbing properties of the surrounding
atmosphere the greenhouse effect mm-hmm
so what is it so you guys are looking at
all of this information and you see this
and I hear a lot of people say well the
earth has gone through cooling periods
and warming periods and all of this
stuff and you've heard all of it
obviously how do you make the direct
correlation between what humans are
doing and the actual growth yeah it's a
great question and in you allude to one
of the critical issues here which is
it's really the rate of changes that we
are seeing and you have a theory behind
this you came up with the hockey stick
theory that really explains the rate
right in a sense the hockey stick curve
we published it's hard to believe more
than a decade and a half ago and there
are many other studies now that come to
the same conclusion that yeah the recent
warming is unprecedented as far back as
we can go
thousands of years
but even over longer time frames let's
go back to the age of dinosaurs okay
there was a time in the early period the
Cretaceous period when dinosaurs roamed
the planet a hundred million years ago
when we know that concentrations of
carbon dioxide were actually
substantially higher than they are today
and we know that the earth was very warm
at that time in fact it was basically as
warm as we would expect give is it how
do we know that from from the carbon
dioxide how do we actually know because
I think a lot of it's people just hear
that they say well the carbon dioxide
was more but what does that have to do
with the temperature yeah so the way we
know temperatures were warm geologists
can see when there's evidence of ice and
we know that we had an ice-free planet
there was no evidence of any you know
the sort of scraping of rocks that you
would get if you had ice sheets so we're
quite certain that the earth was
ice-free at that time and if you do the
calculations that's consistent with the
earth having been several degrees warmer
than it is today
and so the critics will point to that
right let's say well here was a natural
warm period there weren't any SUVs
around back then and it's true that over
a time scale of a hundred million years
nature is pretty powerful and nature can
vary the concentrations of these
greenhouse gases on those timescales
through changes in volcanic activity
plate tectonics so over a time scale of
a hundred million years nature is pretty
powerful and the concentrations of these
greenhouse gases on those timescales are
ruled by things like volcanic eruptions
plate tectonics what we're doing is
we're taking all of that carbon that was
buried naturally by the earth over that
ensuing hundred million years since the
early cretaceous as the climate slowly
cooled down nature slowly buried all
that carbon what we're doing is we're
not digging it up when we're putting it
back into the atmosphere but we're doing
it over a time scale of about a century
a million times faster than Whitney
would be able to do on its own and so
that's really the issue we're talking
about rates of change that exceed
anything that living things let alone us
have had to adapt to in our past right
so when you see that then that is the
obvious link to the the new variable
here is us right I mean is that just is
that as easily as you can make that jump
then yeah I mean if you look at the
concentrations of co2 in the atmosphere
in just a week ago I was out at the
Scripps Institution for oceanography in
San Diego which is one of the world's
leading institutes for climate studies
and it's also it was the home of Charles
Keeling who back in 1958 first began
measurements of atmospheric co2 on mon
aloha on the top of this mountain in
hawaii this very pristine location and
many of your viewers will have seen the
famous Keeling curve which shows how co2
has increased over time and there's a
little bit of an annual wiggle and
that's sort of an interesting part of
the curve it has to do with the seasons
mm-hmm but you see this inexorable climb
and that climb took us past a new
threshold a few years ago we crossed 400
parts per million co2 in the atmosphere
pre-industrial levels were about 280
so we crossed 400 parts per million for
the first time in what we think is
literally millions of years wow so it is
an unprecedented experiment that we are
performing with this one planet that we
know which can you know provide a home
for us yeah so everything that you've
laid out to me sounds like science it
sounds like these are quantifiable
testable practices that you and your
colleagues have used to come up with
some answers here but I know that
there's a certain amount of people and
unfortunately it's a it's a large amount
of people even if we don't want it to be
that simply don't believe in just some
of the things you're talking about so
for example if you were to say well
millions of years ago this x y&z
happened well they would say well
actually you know according to the Bible
the earth is only a couple thousand
years old or something like that how do
you fight
that because you're trying to use
science and rationality and this is I
talked about this in the in the
political arena all the time you know if
you're trying to talk rationality and
someone else is just trying to talk you
know well my my imaginary friend or
whatever it is that's a tough battle to
win yeah absolutely and it's battle we
constantly fight when it comes to any
area of science where there's a
potential conflict between the findings
of science and the beliefs of certain
groups of people obviously with the
theory of evolution there's some
opposition to the theory of evolution
that comes from certain parts of the
religious community although I would
note that the Pope for example it firmly
accepts the science of evolution he also
firmly accepts the science of climate
change yeah octi has been a very
important messenger when it comes to the
issue but I think what you find is that
there's a phenomenon that has been
termed cognate
cultural cognition and there's a
scientist Dan kahan at Yale who studies
this see and what he's looking at is how
do people process information that
they're provided and it turns out one of
the things that's very relevant here is
that people will often they have sort of
an ideological filter for the way they
take in information and that filter will
reject those you know facts those pieces
of information that conflict with their
underlying worldview outlook ideology
you know sometimes go cognitive
dissonance right but what it means is
that you can't reach those people simply
with facts because they're not really
looking at it in terms of the evidence
per se they're looking at this as well
you know I'm part of a try I'm a loyal
you know a tea party Republican and I
know that tea party Republicans are
against climate change so
it's irrelevant whether they're against
climate change because climate change is
still coming for you right it doesn't
care you know whether you're Republican
or a Democrat present but nonetheless it
turns out it's difficult to reach those
folks because they're not necessarily
open to being convinced by logic by data
by facts there are ways to reach those
folks and there are a number of
researchers and just practitioners who
are out there trying to find ways to
communicate to those who have otherwise
been sort of resistant to accepting the
science of climate change resistant to
believing a pointy-headed academic like
me but you know you get a four-star
general in front of them or a former
congressman like Bob Inglis of South
Carolina it was a conservative
Republican had a nearly perfect you you
may you may have even talked with him at
some well he a fascinating guy had a
perfect conservative voting record or
near-perfect one in one of the reddest
parts one of the reddest districts in
South Carolina with an overwhelming
amount of support sixty something
percent from the vote but he made the
mistake of speaking out about the issue
of climate change on the House floor
he's an evangelical Christian and he
sees this as a matter of preserving
creation for future generations and he
decided that he really needed to speak
out about climate change well that
earned him the ire of the Koch brothers
who heavily funded a primary opponent
trey Gowdy mm-hmm heard of of course who
defeated him in the primary election
what they didn't expect is that Bob
Inglis now in need of a job would decide
to devote himself to talking to
conservative audiences and talking about
how free-market approaches to dealing
with this problem makes sense in terms
of conservative principles and trying to
convince some of those some of those
folks who again might be resistant to
being told something by you know a
pointy headed academic or a sign
test but you know by a fellow
conservative who shares very much shares
their values um you know perhaps there's
room for to make headway there so are
you amazed how politicized this has
become because for me it's like you
can't choose whether to believe in
science I always say you know I'm not a
scientist so if I'm going to talk about
these things I have to find some people
that have done the work and and trust
them and then if someone comes along and
and disproves what they're saying so be
it I'll look at new evidence after but I
can't pretend that I know what's going
to happen here and this has become and I
think you've already alluded to it
probably a lot because of the Koch
brothers this has become incredibly
politicized so first can you talk a
little bit about what the Koch brothers
involvement in sort of the answering
science part of this is and then just
generally how that steep how that sort
of moved into the political arena sure
thing and in fact I've seen the sort of
efforts of the Koch brothers firsthand
in my book the hockey stick and the
climate Wars I talk about all the
attacks that were lodged against me
you've had a lot of attacks I I went
through the list and I thought we could
go into this but I wanted to really
stick to the to the point ya know and
it's because the hockey stick which we
spoke briefly about this curve that
showed how unprecedented recent warming
is in a long-term context that was seen
as a threat to the forces of inaction to
those who oppose regulating carbon
emissions because it told a simple story
that people could understand and because
of that I think those you know the
forces of denial saw it necessary to try
to discredit me personally huh in an
effort to discredit the hockey stick and
they've been trying I've been fighting
back for from you know well over a
decade now and a lot of those efforts it
turns out he scratched just a little bit
beneath the surface what you find is
that a lot of these are paid advocates
front groups organizations that are
funded guess what by the Koch brothers
and so a lot of this that you know the
so-called Tea Party in a sense was
manufactured by the Koch brothers
Americans for Prosperity
you know this is a lofty sounding group
who couldn't be for Prosperity they're
really good with the names all of these
groups right now they only those guys
they can't be bad guys they're for
goodness and prosperity yeah if they
call themselves uh citizens for dirty
fossil fuel energy for a little more
truth in advertising right maybe uh you
know they wouldn't get as much support
but they're very good at that they're
very good at reframing the debate making
it about values seemingly making it
about the economy you know that uh
acting on this problem will destroy the
economy when just the opposite is true
and if you talk to leading off the
economists will tell you the cost of
inaction right now is already far
greater than the cost of taking action
and just look at you know sandy
hurricane sandy a storm that we know is
made worse by climate change